diskutiert wird momentan das thema
ausgangs beschränkung ausgangssperre
wir erleben dass in diesen stunden und
corona kim und kabinett darüber
diskutiert wurde oder scholz hat gesagt
er sieht das skeptisch was die ausgangs
beschränkung angeht wie stehen sie zu
dem thema das ja relativ überraschend
plötzlich gestern aus dem kanzleramt
denn das papier geschrieben wurde er uns
aber ich will ihnen sagen ich halte
davon nichts
die ausgangssperre ist ein instrument
das in meinen augen nicht nicht greift
also die menschen sind doch vernünftig
in diesem land und ich erlebe seit über
einem jahr dass sich die menschen an die
regeln halten glaube wir müssen in der
politik jetzt dringend und das muss auch
heute noch mal passiert darüber reden
wie wir bei zwei zentralen elementen aus
diesem loch down raus kommen oder mit
zwei zentral des eines testen und ihre
strategie das andere schimpfen aber eine
ausgangssperre sage ich ihnen nicht die
lösung die menschen halten sich doch
eher an die regeln sind nachts nicht auf
der straße und das ist kein instrument
das die zweite riecht dann erklären sie
mir wie so etwas passieren kann wie wird
plötzlich so ein thema ausgangssperren
ein papier geschrieben wo er die
menschen eigentlich die hoffnung haben
dass es jetzt besser werden sollte
können sie sich erklären was da momentan
im kanzleramt passiert meine herren das
kann ich nicht ich kann nicht erklären
die kanzlerin hat ist jetzt zum
wiederholten male jetzt ein papiere
reingeschrieben ist nicht das erste mal
ich glaube dass das wäre ein instrument
das ohne wirkung bleibt das ohne wirkung
ist wir müssen über andere dinge reden
beim testen besser werden beim impfen
besser werden kontakt nachverfolgung
aber eine nächtliche ausgangssperre wo
sie hier lernen die regeln halten sehe
ich nicht als effizienter wenn ich mir
jetzt dieses papier anschauen ich nehme
an sie haben es mittlerweile auch
gelesen dann wirkt das wie ein papier
des scheiterns deshalb weil bei uns das
test nicht funktioniert und das impfen
nicht funktioniert ist es ihnen
mittlerweile peinlich teil dieser
regierung zu sein
nein das ist mir nicht peinlich das ist
eine ganz schwierige lage die wir im
land haben und politik wird viel
abverlangt ich finde nach wie vor dass
wir in der pandemie vernünftig als
deutschland gestartet sind dass viele
sachen gelungen sind dass sie richtig
gelaufen sind und dass jetzt aber in der
tat dinge falsch laufen und über die und
das habe ich gerade gesagt
meine erwartung muss heute nachmittag
geredet werden impfen testen
kontakte nach verfolgen das ist der weg
raus ich auch nicht mal darüber reden
wer diese verantwortung hat und wie es
sein kann dass wahrscheinlich in jedem
mittelständischen unternehmen oder
dax-unternehmen ist längst
verantwortliche gegeben hätte die zum
rücktritt gedrängt worden wären oder die
selbst diesen rücktritt vollzogen hätten
wie kann es sein dass wir seit monaten
scheitern bei diesen entscheidenden
themen ist aber keine konsequenzen gibt
wer da draußen soll das noch verstehen
dass der impfstoff nicht kommt dass das
testen nicht geht dass sie aber an der
regierung alle zusammen weiter wussten
also erstmal glaube ich kann man gerade
mir nicht vorwerfen dass ich nicht
missstände auch kritisiert hätte
übrigens auch in diesem format und
wissen sie da habe ich viel für auf den
deckel bekommen dass mir gesagt wurde du
darfst doch jetzt nicht den
gesundheitsminister kritisieren du
darfst das mit dem impfen nicht
kritisieren aber ich bleibe dabei das
ist der weg raus aus der krise und
deswegen müssen wir das ansprechen
deswegen muss es besser werden und mir
geht es gar nicht um
rücktrittsforderungen mir geht es gar
nicht darum der personelle konsequenzen
zu fordern
ich erwarte von allen ein job in der
regierung machen dass sie jetzt 24 7
alles tun damit wir das raus können und
dass dann nicht ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen wie heute stattfinden wo wir
wieder über weitere beschränkungen
nachdenken sondern impfen testen
kontakte nachverfolgen
da muss druck sein und das muss auch
nochmal heute ein klares signal werden
aber mit dem impfen funktioniert sie
arbeiter nicht klingen weil jetzt hören
wir dass das bei den hausärzten losgehen
soll die kriegen aber nur 20 dosen und
jetzt hören wir schon dass da die
leitungen voll sind dass die menschen
versuchen anzurufen wie verzweifelt aber
keine termine bekommen wer hat sich das
denn jetzt schon wieder ausgedacht
das ist ja ein ergebnis auch der der
runde der ministerpräsidenten
aber es bleibt gerade noch das problem
wir haben zu wenig impfstoff ist richtig
dass die hausärzte übrigens ich finde
auch die betriebsärzte müssen mit rein
in die infrastruktur mit aufgenommen
werden ich habe mich gerade im wahlkreis
auch im eigenen impfzentrum war ich da
die können viel mehr impfen als es heute
der fall ist und ich zähle darauf dass
das gilt was in der regierung jetzt auch
angekündigt wurde in den nächsten vier
wochen wird es wesentlich mehr impfstoff
geben und dann kommen wir hoffentlich
mit dieser verbesserten infrastruktur
voran
es ist ein mühsamer prozess ist ist
kräftezehrend ist nervt auch an vielen
stellen
aber wir müssen beim impfen vorankommen
und die infrastruktur ist da jetzt muss
der impfstoff kommen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren